gonna rescind this governor's Medicaid  Waiver  we're gonna give this state a brand-new  Board of Education  [Applause]  and we are going to restore the Voting  Rights of more than 140,000 citizens  everyday we're going to work to expand  access to health care and we are gonna  fight to lower the cost of prescription  drugs health care is a basic human right  and my administration will treat it as  such under our administration a pension  is a promise there will be no more going  after more going after the pensions of  OSHA workers and first responders they  have earned that retirement and public  education will be the central priority  of my administration we are going to  invest in our public schools because we  believe in the next generation of  Kentuckians our schools are the  foundation of our communities every kid  has the right to get a world-class  education that opens up every door that  they can walk through  [Music]  and we can only provide those  opportunities by insurer